TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, internet,
and welcome to yet
another episode of "Game On."
I'm Todd Kerpelman.
I'm a Developer Advocate here
on the Play Games team.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Hey,
I'm Duncan Curtis.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Play team.
And I've just launched the
Google Play Games app.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, well, that's
very convenient because
that happens to bring
us to this week's
episode, Episode Six.
We're going to be talking about
the Play Games app.
Before we get into that though,
let's talk about some
other news and updates.
The first thing is that some
of you might have noticed
there is a new update to
Play Services that has
been rolling out.
And I think by the time this
video launches, it should be
out to all of the world.
What's new for you on the Play
Games Services side of things?
Not much, so it's not a very
exciting announcement.
But we did introduce a number
of bug fixes, a lot in Real
Time Multiplayer.
And there's been this image
loader crash, that I know has
been driving people crazy over
on the public bug database.
So that has finally
been addressed.
Thanks everyone for
your patience.
And by the way, proof
that the public bug
database actually works.
That's how we caught this one.
So remember, visit that.
And we'll add on a link here.
And report any issues that
you find because
apparently it works.
In addition, if you can't get
enough of me, if you're
saying, once every two weeks
is just not enough Todd, I
have started a new "DevBytes"
series, which is introducing
Play Games for iOS.
It's a series of screen casts
where we're going to go
through adding Sign In,
Achievements, Leader Boards,
some sharing on Google+
to an iOS application.
So go ahead and follow along or
share it with your favorite
iOS developer.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Are you
saying that's like
now 100% more Todd?
TODD KERPELMAN: 100%
more Todd.
DUNCAN CURTIS: That's
fantastic.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's actually
going to be
like 600% more Todd.
This is like three
times a week.
DUNCAN CURTIS: This is news.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's honestly
more Todd than most of you
really want.
So I won't be offended if
that's too much Todd.
Anyway, we should go on to our
main topic here, which is the
Play Games app.
Yes, Duncan, you've been in
charge of this thing now.
I know we just launched
a release.
Is there anything exciting
in this week's release?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yes.
Actually, we've got some
really cool stuff.
So first, I'll discussed a
little bit about the app.
And then I'll maybe go through
and talk about some things
that have updated.
You all know the
Play Games app.
It's the hub of gaming for
Android as it grows.
And more features
are rolling out.
It's becoming the place you
go when you want to
do gaming on Android.
And that's a good for
developers, because now we've
got a place for everyone
to go, not just a
vertical in the store.
We've now got our own app.
It also lets people game with
each other, find each other,
track their progress in your
games, your games, where you
mark your own achievements and
let people update them.
And they get to track their
progress and also discover new
titles, discover some of your
titles, discover what their
friends are playing.
Maybe their friends are
playing your game now.
So I think, perhaps it's
best if I show you.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would be good.
Let's go to a demo.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Cool, so here's
the Home screen of the
destination app as everyone
knows and loves.
We've got the My games section
at the top, which shows all
your Play Enabled games.
TODD KERPELMAN: So now, are
these all games that you have
installed on the device?
DUNCAN CURTIS: No, it's whatever
you've played most
recently on the Play
enabled games.
So you could have
been playing--
just a hop back to you
"DevBytes" series, you could
have been playing a Play-Enabled
game on iOS.
And it will still
show up here.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
OK.
So basically, this list is
populated based on the most
recent games I've been
playing, using
the Play Games service.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Correct.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
DUNCAN CURTIS: It also, for the
users, it shows the number
of achievements they've got,
to sort of drive people who
really love to get that
100% achievement
complete on a game.
If they can see here that,
you've got your 28 of 29
achievements, very likely to
jump back into your game, even
if it's down in the fourth
or fifth slot.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Next we have
the Player section.
These are all of your G+ friends
who are Play enabled,
so people who are actually
gaming and
have been gaming recently.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So this is people in my Google+
Circles who have used
a game, using Play Services.
So basically, we know,
hey, these guys have
signed into a game.
They're gaming. they're probably
people you can play a
multiplayer game with.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Exactly.
As you can see, here
is Ellie Powers.
And she's been playing our
fantastic sample app,
Nostalgic Racer.
So if I jump on into--
TODD KERPELMAN: How did
you know she was
playing Nostalgic Racer?
DUNCAN CURTIS: So if I jump back
up for one second, see,
in the bottom right-hand
corner, just here--
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, yeah.
There's that little icon.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Little
icons, yeah.
So it's really great because
if you're a big fan of
Nostalgic Racer, as I clearly
am, and say, for example,
Triple Town-- shout out to Spry
Fox, great game-- so if
you're a fan of one of these
games, it makes you much more
likely to be like, hey, I should
go check out other
games that this friend
has been playing.
So yeah, I'll dive in
there a little bit
more deeply in a minute.
Here we have our
Featured games.
So this is where we're showing
the list of featured titles
that are Play enabled.
Now, we have just released one
update here as well, which
I'll point out.
It's that, installed or
purchased titles will no
longer show up in this list, if
there's more featured games
for you to show.
TODD KERPELMAN: So if I already
had Monster Shooter--
DUNCAN CURTIS: It would no
longer show up in this row,
unless you had all of our
featured games, which is a
happy problem.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
DUNCAN CURTIS: What that really
means is that, for
developers, specifically for
developers, this is going to
be really important.
Because if you do make our
Featured list, then it doesn't
matter if your number one
in the Featured list.
You still have a really great
chance of getting high levels
of visibility in the
Play Games app.
TODD KERPELMAN: So now,
how do I get on this
Featured games list?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Featured games
list is a hand curated list by
our BD team.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, so I've
got to make a game that
impresses our BD team?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: I should
probably enable Game Services?
DUNCAN CURTIS: That's a
minimum requirement.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And I'm assuming this list-- is
this a completely separate
list than, say, some
of the featured
lists in the Play store?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Correct.
That's correct.
There's a completely separate
list that we take care of,
because we're gamers.
We what we want.
And we like we like a really
great integrations.
So there's some really good
example integrations, if you
check that out Dev Docs,
for great ways to
integrate our service.
There are basic ways to do it.
And then, there are
really cool and
impressive ways to do it.
So we're always looking
for that
dare to be great situation.
TODD KERPELMAN: So these tend
to be good games that also
have really nice integrations.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yes.
It certainly makes
it more common.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
Yeah, keep going.
DUNCAN CURTIS: So the other
list is, You may know.
So You may know is a place for
you to find people that,
Google+ back end has said, hey,
these people you know, so
a good place for you to most
likely find your friends.
TODD KERPELMAN: So are these
people already in my Circles?
These are people not in my
Circles, but Google+ thinks I
probably know them.
DUNCAN CURTIS: You probably
know them.
There's probably
a good chance.
TODD KERPELMAN: And are these
people necessarily gamers?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Not
at this stage.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
DUNCAN CURTIS: However, you're
probably going to know which
ones of your friends
are gamers anyway.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
DUNCAN CURTIS: So one of the
other updates we've recently
released is that, some of these
rows for Players is and
for You may know, when you jump
into a next level down--
so for example, if I jump into
a player and jump back up, if
I had more than three players
here, if I had more than the
maximum row number, we would
actually cycle between some of
the players, so that you can
see a bit more of what your
friends are doing.
That also applies to the
You may know row.
It's that we want to really just
filter through that list
a little more quickly and let
you get a chance to see some
more people.
TODD KERPELMAN: You're right.
That list looks different.
DUNCAN CURTIS: It is different
from the last time.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow, magic.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yeah.
So just minor tweaks and
tunes, here and there.
I did want to jump in and just
show you a little bit of the
cool thing with Players.
We mentioned earlier that
Ellie had been playing
Nostalgic Racer.
And as I love it, I would
like to see what
else Ellie is playing.
Here, I can see all the other
Play enabled games that Ellie
has been playing.
And I can jump straight into
one, like Triple Town.
Wow, here's a little bit
about Triple Town.
Here are the game features
that it uses.
As you can see there at the top,
it uses Achievements and
Leader Boards.
And since I haven't got the game
installed yet, I haven't
got any Achievements.
But I can check the Achievements
out, before I
even own the game.
So this is a good reason for
developers to implement really
great art and useful text that
can be explained to users
quite easily.
Because I can see if there's
interesting things here to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, now, I
noticed you got here by going
through Ellie's profile.
Can I see Ellie's
achievements?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Not yet.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
Not yet, meaning that it's a
good idea and maybe just--
DUNCAN CURTIS: It is
a fantastic idea.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
That's what I want to hear.
Let's go back to the About
section for one second.
Where does this information
come from?
Where do we get these badges?
Is that automatic?
Where is this description?
So the badging features come
from-- when you enable your
game in Dev Console, you get
to say, hey, these are the
features I'm using.
We have some smarts on the
back end that determine
legitimate use of the service.
And if that passes, then your
badging will show up, both
here and in the Play store.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So that's basically--
I know Triple Town has gone,
and they've added
achievements.
And they obviously have
leaderboards.
And so our system has basically
detected that.
And they sort of get the
badges automatically.
There's nothing additional the
developer needs to do.
DUNCAN CURTIS: No.
You're correct.
As soon as they start sending
us the signals and have
everything enabled in the Dev
Console, it just works.
The description is being pulled
from the Play store.
And we're looking at updating
some features in the future,
to make this more interactive,
more interesting.
But this is where we
are for the moment.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wait, is it
actually from the Play store?
Or is it from the Developer
Console?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Oh, sorry.
It's from the Developer
Console.
We just did the update.
You got me, well played.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thanks.
See, I know a thing or two.
DUNCAN CURTIS: We just recently
released an update to
the Dev Console, where you'll be
able to do some copying and
pasting automatically,
which will be nice.
So from here, users
can jump into the
Play store to purchase.
Or they can just launch the game
in the top right, where
it's got free, over here.
TODD KERPELMAN: So clicking
on that will take
me to the Play store?
DUNCAN CURTIS: For now, it
will take you to the Play
store, where you can install.
And then, if you have this
installed from here, you can
just click Play, straight
from there.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
You say, for now, meaning that,
you've got other ideas
maybe in the future for what
that button could do?
DUNCAN CURTIS: It goes
to the Play store.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm going to
get you to commit to some
future feature at some point.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yeah.
So we talked about
achievements.
I'd like to talk about
leaderboards a
little bit as well.
So just for developers to know,
you can have more than
one leaderboard.
So you can have your
high score.
Let's say, it was
a high score.
As you can see here, you can
have daily, weekly, or
all-time leaderboards.
That's up to the user
to take a look at.
But you can also have multiple
leaderboards.
So for a car racing game, this
could be drift versus drag
racing versus carjacking, if
you're in GTA or something.
But this is the ability for
people to compete in multiple
different ways, how they
want to compete.
So within here, the player can
see people within their
Circles that are competing and
also the entire public
leaderboard.
So this gives people a chance
to compete in multiple
different ways within
your game.
So integrate leaderboards.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
It sounds good.
So I was going to say, we
provide the ability for
developers to show leaderboards
in their games already.
But I suppose the advantage here
is, I don't need to go
and install the game before I
get to see the leaderboards.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Correct.
So you can go check out the
leaderboard of any game.
So I don't even have
Triple Town
installed on this account.
Trust me, I have it
on other accounts.
But you can go check it out and
see what's a good score.
You can also get an idea.
If a friend of yours has been
bragging about getting two
million in Triple Town.
And you go to the leaderboard,
and you're like, but 28
million is what the
top guy has.
Then you can quickly
get a feel for how
your friend is doing.
I would like to point out that,
you mentioned something
interesting about Leaderboards
and Achievements.
Developers can use our APIs and
implement whatever user
interface they want in their
game, if they choose.
We do provide client UIs, so
that everyone has a basic
experience and is really quick
to get up and going.
But irrespective of the way you
implement on your side,
they'll show up here, in the of
Play Games app, like this.
That way, there's a consistent
experience for users in the
gaming hub.
I think that's about all I
really wanted to talk about
for the moment.
I'm really happy with
this minor update.
We had some bug fixes,
which is nice, a
little bit more stability.
The changes are a little bit
more flow through of the
players in the different cards,
so you can see more.
And we've got lots more exciting
things to come.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, that sounds good.
Well then, maybe let's just jump
into some follow up Q&A.
Starting with-- so where
is this app?
How do I get it?
DUNCAN CURTIS: You can get
it in the Play store.
If you look for Play Games,
you can get it there.
And some devices come with
it pre-installed.
TODD KERPELMAN: Do you
know which ones?
DUNCAN CURTIS: It's
ever increasing.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
I do know that, right now, if
you get the new Nexus 7, it
comes with that installed.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Nexus
7, it does.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK,
so Nexus 7--
and so the people that are using
the Play Games app right
now are people that have
actually gone out and said, I
want to install this app.
And so they're probably
a good audience.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yeah.
They're a great audience.
We've got a really
engaged audience
with really good retention.
So getting your game in now, in
the early stages, as this
app is taking off, it's a really
great way to find those
dedicated gamers.
There are not as many
games as we want
yet, using our services.
I mean, we've still got a
massive slew of them.
And it's been fantastic.
Thank you, developers, for so
many of you integrating.
But not everyone has
done it yet.
So it's a really great
opportunity for some of the
indie devs to come on, integrate
our service, have a
great integration and be able to
get featured or have it go
through the system
like wildfire,
in these early stages.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
Well you sort of answered
our second question.
But yeah, I'm a developer.
What do I get for--
why do I care about this app?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Well, this
comes for free.
So if you integrate our Play
Games services, you get shown
up here for free.
So people will be able
to search for
your game in the future.
We have, as you can see--
let me just go down.
Can we just switch back to
the demo for one second?
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
We're there.
DUNCAN CURTIS: So Popular is
actually a list of all our
most popular Play
enabled games.
So this is similar to on the
Play store, where there are
the top Free or top Pay games.
These are the top Play
enabled games.
So if you're a developer,
you care.
Because if you integrate, you
can get straight on this list.
And I guarantee you.
We check this list
very regularly.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
So if I click on one of these,
am I able to find out say,
Temple Run 2, which of my
friends are playing this?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Not yet.
TODD KERPELMAN: Not yet.
There's that word again, yet.
All right.
And then I notice you also
have a list for Popular
Multiplayer.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yes.
So we have got a list of popular
multiplayer games.
TODD KERPELMAN: I haven't
seen that before.
DUNCAN CURTIS: You haven't
seen it before?
TODD KERPELMAN: I
guess I should.
DUNCAN CURTIS: You should
probably take a look at that.
TODD KERPELMAN: I should try
this app or something.
DUNCAN CURTIS: You should
really try this app.
So basically, we're rolling out
different ways for users
to find your game, by the way
they use our services.
We have Popular Multiplayer
for now.
But you could only imagine that
we would want to do other
things in the future.
So we haven't got them yet.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
Well, this might be a very
useful instance where I might
want to see which of my friends
are playing this
Popular Multiplayer game.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Exactly.
If you want to jump in and see
who's playing Super Stickman
Golf right now, you
can jump in.
And if I did have any friends
playing, in the future, it
would show up there
as an extra tab.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would be awesome.
I can't wait for that, which
you're launching next week.
Is that right?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Oh, clearly.
Next week, that's the
one, just having
rolled out a release.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So that was sarcasm, for those
of you not in product
development.
All right, cool.
So it seems like there are kind
of various avenues to
getting my game either
discovered or rediscovered.
What seems to be the
most popular?
Is it people look at the games
they recently played, and
they're like, oh,
yeah, I remember
playing that yesterday?
Is it the featured stuff?
Is it the, hey, here's what
my friends are playing?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Re-engagement
is really good.
So we find people
open the app.
And they're like, oh, yeah.
They can see the games they've
been playing recently.
And if they're not feeling like
playing that one game
they've been playing the most
recently, it's a really great
way to reengage.
As I said before, there
are Achievements.
If you've got 28 or 29
Achievements, a great reason
to jump back in and finish
that last one off.
It's also about discovery.
Discovery has been really
good for us.
And featuring is obviously
a really, really
great way to get that.
TODD KERPELMAN: What are other
ways I can maximize my
discovery potential, be of
besides getting featured,
which is nice?
DUNCAN CURTIS: The
more services you
integrate, the better.
So there are different ways
to get discovered
for different services.
So for example, the Multiplayer
is a unique
service this at the moment, that
has its own entire tab.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And let's go into one of
these games again.
Is there anything you recommend,
in terms of
description, that maybe I
could do to improve the
experience?
Or is it kind at the same
guidelines as the Play store?
DUNCAN CURTIS: It's the same
guidelines as the Play store.
And we'll be improving this in
the future, to give you more
ways to do it.
But once again, I would say,
try to have really good
achievement art and
leaderboard art.
So you can see here that, while
the developer hasn't
chosen to specify icons, if we
jump back up to Triple Town,
which I went through Ellie to
find, we have individual icons
for each leaderboard.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'd say, these
look more appealing.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So maybe that's good advice
to developers.
I suppose, if I'm a big
developer and I'm implementing
my own leaderboard UI, I might
not think that adding
leaderboard icons
is important.
Because I'm like,
I don't use it.
That's not how I'm doing
it in my game.
But it's still going
to show up here.
DUNCAN CURTIS: That's right.
So I'd advise, whatever
developer you are, go check
your game out in the
Play Games app, if
you've already launched.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
That sounds good.
Is there a way for me to preview
my game in the Play
Games app before
I've launched?
DUNCAN CURTIS: Not yet.
TODD KERPELMAN: Not yet.
He keeps using that word.
Is it really just because you
don't want to say, no?
And you think that's--
DUNCAN CURTIS: I don't want
to say, no to you, Todd.
But they're all great
features.
I mean, these are definitely--
they're all great features.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, that sounds good.
So developers, if you've
launched your game, check it
out in the Play Games app.
Make sure it looks good.
Make sure it looks like
something people would be
interested in playing.
And I guess let us know if
you have suggestions.
I think we might even have an
entry in the public bug
database for the Play Games
destination app.
So that any enhancements or
any requests or all those
things that I just mentioned,
go ahead and add them.
So we'll add some
peer pressure.
And see if we can get Duncan
and his team to
add some more stuff.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Thanks.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, I think that wraps it up
for this biweekly episode of
"Game On." Thank you, Duncan,
for coming out and explaining
everything to us about
the Play Games app.
DUNCAN CURTIS: Thanks
for having me talk.
TODD KERPELMAN: You're going to
come back, when there's a
new, exciting announcement.
DUNCAN CURTIS: You'll see
me back regularly.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, excellent.
I can't wait.
Thank you very much,
YouTube audience.
And we will see you in
a couple of weeks.